tipo è sparita ma
[Musica]
Ascolta Mi è venuta un'idea
lui ci troverà qualcosa quando ci
troverà puntiamogli subito le torcere in
faccia e proviamo ad accecarlo una volta
che lo cercheremo scapperemo da quella
parte va bene Sei sicuro che sia una
buona idea No però dobbiamo provarci
pensieri di pronto
scappa scappa
non so quando riuscirà a mantenere
adesso che cosa facciamo
Aspettiamo che se ne vada
sento dei passi che si allontanano
è andato via ho sentito una porta
Sì forse vorrei provare a raggiungerci
dalla finestra
chiudiamo la finestra
ora l'unica cosa da fare è aspettare che
torni la mattina
se questa è una notte di luna piena
e lui tornerà normale domani mattina
quindi non ci resta che aspettare non
possiamo fare altro Altrimenti verremo
sbranati Ok quindi dobbiamo solo
aspettare vero
ok
[Musica]
niente
Vitale sveglia
Sì
non ci vado a scuola
ho capito Devo svegliarlo alla vecchia
maniera la
colazione
Dov'è la colazione Ecco ha funzionato Ti
ricordi che siamo in questa casa e
stiamo scappando da una creatura gigante
un lupo mannaro gigantesco
non pensare a colazione adesso potrebbe
ancora essere qua pensi che sia ancora
qua la creatura Non lo so perché se c'è
una cosa che so sui lupi mannari è che
durante la luna piena si trasformano ma
poi la mattina tornano normali quindi
potrebbe essere tornato normale
Magari magari è andato via allora non
possiamo andare a fare colazione adesso
ma non pensare alla colazione adesso
dobbiamo assicurarci che sia andato via
davvero che sia tornato normale
fiamma
per tutte le creature fiamma Dobbiamo
controllare come sta
sembra non esserci
meglio rimanere prudenti Ok ma tanto sei
il lupo mannaro e giorno sarà andato via
No non è detto perché
Vabbè te lo dico dopo me lo dici dopo
cosa c'è una possibilità che è
possibilità te lo spiego Adesso dobbiamo
andare a vedere come sta fiamma Ok va
bene ma poi dopo me lo spieghi
Ecco questa è la porta della camera di
fiamma vediamo prima se sentiamo qualche
rumore
mi sembra il momento di fare scherzi
ai rumori hai ragione scusami
che cosa è successo qui
sembra che sia esplosa una bomba
fiamma
Guarda la finestra è aperta Magari il
lupo mannaro ha preso fiamma ed è uscito
fuori dalla finestra
Beh in effetti potrebbe essere passato
di qua visto il caos che c'è qua dentro
cerchiamo qualche indizio
Che strano Non mi sembrano vestiti di
fiamma questi vedi non sembrano vestiti
da donna
è un po' strana quindi potrebbero
benissimo essere i suoi vestiti
Chissà se poi fiamma La Preparati per
davvero quei biscotti
me li ha promessi sono quasi pronti
quasi pronti quasi pronti però poi dopo
me li ha fatti mica a mangiare
Ma possibile che pensi sempre ai
biscotti Dobbiamo trovare una creatura
enorme il lupo mannaro più grande che io
abbia mai visto finora alla fine
potrebbe anche essere fiamma La creatura
è strano che si è sparita cioè è troppo
una coincidenza fiamma è sparita e
apparsa la creatura di nuovo è sparita
ma
Ah ah ah ah
ah
scappiamo scappiamo non chiusa a chiave
l'ho chiusa a chiave
C'è mancato poco E ora che facciamo
dobbiamo nasconderci da qualche parte
presto
Ma qui ci vede
Non mi sembra proprio un buon
nascondiglio questo non è proprio il
massimo
Si vede che siamo nascosti sì
Speriamo solo di averlo chiuso bene a
chiave che cosa avevi chiuso la finestra
No non avevo chiuso la finestra perché
non dovevo chiuderla perché sarà uscito
dalla ci starà cercando
ma scusami ma tu non mi avevi detto che
i lupi mannari si trasformano solo di
notte e con la luna piena oggi è tipo
giorno e di giorno non dovrebbe essere
trasformato no E infatti è come temevo
un'antica leggenda narra che esistono
dei lupi mannari che sono in grado di
trasformarsi a comando quando vogliono
indipendentemente dalla luna piena o dal
buio o dal sole e dal giorno dalla luce
credo che questo sia una di quelle razze
di lupi mannari Ma chi te l'ha
raccontata questa leggenda Beh è una
leggenda che mi ha raccontato l'ex il
lupo Ti ricordi l'ex lui è un esperto di
mostri un mostrologo mi aveva raccontato
di questo nuovo mannaro ma pensavo che
non esistessero i lupi mannare così ma
evidentemente esistono e sono una razza
più forte o no E adesso cosa facciamo
Cosa possiamo fare qualche idea eh
Qualche idea Lo sai che io ho delle idee
solo quando si tratta di
Aspetta forse mi è venuto l'idea non mi
dire che sei solo pensando a mangiare
come sempre Non solo pensando a mangiare
come sempre Però potrebbe esserci
qualcosa di buono che ne esce fuori eh
tu aspettami qua non ti preoccupare Ci
penso io Copriti bene qui con Il
nascondiglio Ok so quello che faccio o
almeno ci credo Stai attento
speriamo che abbia avuto davvero una
buona idea e non una delle sue trovate
per riuscire a mangiare di più
Se non ricordo male erano proprio qui
sì Non mi sbagliavo
Eccoli i biscotti
sono ancora buoni
amore
o no
sono spacciato adesso sono spacciato
le stai bene
mi hai salvato Grazie praticamente
Ah questo vassoio d'argento e mi ha
aiutato contro contro il lupo mannaro
aspetta spiegami cosa ci facevi in
questa stanza con questo vassoio mi ero
accorto che c'era questo vassoio coi
biscotti sopra e avevo notato che era un
vassoio d'argento e ho pensato Magari è
un vassoio d'argento che serve come arma
contro i lupi mannari non ci credo sei
stato salvato grazie ai biscotti Grazie
alla tua pancia come sempre ma ora non
perdiamo tempo
[Musica]
dove il lupo mannaro Eh non lo so era lì
un attimo fa Sì pensavo che tu l'avessi
sconfitto
non credo che sia scomparso potrebbe
essere scappato no peccato abbiamo perso
l'occasione di catturare una creatura
così rare e pericolosa e poi c'è sempre
il problema che si ripresenti dici che
torta piano piano
Sì ma quindi sei viva
mi sono persa qualche cosa e stai bene
Sai che abbiamo avuto una nottata un po'
particolare non sei un fantasma vero
che è successo Ragazzi ma metti una cena
bruttissima di successo Beh abbiamo
affrontato la creatura stanotte il lupo
mannaro esatto Ed è stato paurissimo
paurosissimo ma ho una domanda per te Tu
dov'eri tutto quel tempo
è davvero e
dormivo Anita dormivo
Noi siamo entrati in stanza tua e non
c'eri Infatti non c'era nessuno sul
letto
[Applauso]
Ma c'è Ovvio C'è una spiegazione c'è
sempre una spiegazione tutto e sentiamo
quale sarebbe questa spiegazione
sapete io ho difficoltà nell'a
addormentarmi e
ho anche il fatto leggero per cui ho
l'abitudine di dormire
sotto al letto certo
è negli occhi tappi nelle orecchie
persone sono accorta di nulla anzi è
stata una nottata così serena per me in
effetti non abbiamo controllato sotto al
letto Potrebbe essere vero
È verissimo Ma voi Voi come state voi
Beh noi dai abbastanza bene ci siamo
salvati per un pelo Abbiamo affrontato
la creatura Come la creatura Sì è stato
rischioso ma almeno l'abbiamo affrontata
problema è che è scappata scappata
lontano Eh sì sì è scappato lontano
quindi il caso risolto È stato un
piacere piacerissimo Grazie arrivederci
Noi andiamo a fare colazione Io prendo
due croissant e rifacciamo con la crema
e il caffè e il cappuccino il cornetto
il succo di frutta e a presto ci vediamo
presto Tanti saluti grazie
ciao ciao
[Musica]
non è risolto la creatura è scappata
sarebbe risolto se avessimo affrontato
la creatura e l'avrestimo sconfitta qua
è scappata potrebbe
dall'altra parte abbiamo fallito questo
caso mi dispiace no no Anita A quale
fallito Ma voi mi avete salvato mi avete
salvato E non basteranno mille
ringraziamenti grazie grazie sarò sempre
in debito con voi sempre e poi sapete
avete salvato anche le mie scoperte A
tal proposito abbiamo trovato una cosa
molto strana sotterrata in giardino e
beh sembrava tipo una specie di uovo
Dragon round Ma io l'ho sotterrato
perché solo il buio può schiudersi
l'avete visto
sì ma che cos'è questo drago ramo
esattamente
Dunque il drago rana esattamente non
posso spiegare ora Che cos'è però
importantissimo che si schiuda sotto
terra perché potrebbe trasformarsi ma
non so neanche io In che cosa
Sì sì l'abbiamo sotterrato l'abbiamo
sotterrato ma A tal proposito che
facciamo colazione per caso visto che il
caso è chiuso tutto quanto
uomo sotterrato andiamo a mangiare dai
Peccato chiuso non abbiamo risolto un
bel niente La creatura è scappata
l'avremo dovuta a catturare l'avremmo
dovuta eliminare non è risolto proprio
per niente il caso ci siamo fatti
scappare La creatura c'è un lato
positivo in tutta questa faccenda Mi
avete salvata e non basteranno mille
ringraziamenti
avete salvato anche le mie scoperte sarò
sempre in debito con voi Anzi devo
terminare di preparare le mie valigie e
riprendere il viaggio ma come il viaggio
adesso che poi si parlava di colazione
non ci ho offerto neanche il
cioccolatino già se ne va via Eh va via
in vacanza
non è il cioccolatino ma soprattutto i
biscotti
Ma figuriamoci Ma quale vacanza chi ce
l'ha il tempo di andare in vacanza con
tutte le formule che bisogna ancora
scoprire sto andando a cercare l'ultimo
ingrediente per la mia nuova ricetta
un ingrediente molto molto speciale Ah
ho capito Si tratta di quella ricerca
importantissima di cui ci parlavi ieri
ma di cui ancora non ci puoi svelare
niente Beh comunque ti auguro di trovare
l'ingrediente che cerchi Eh
grazie tra virgolette per averci
ospitato in questa casa gigante per noi
ora il momento di andare dobbiamo
tornare dal nostro Merlino e Ciccio e ti
piace la mia gigantesca casa
incidenza Stavo proprio pensando di
farmi una proposta perché non restate
qua restare qua Ma intendi tipo a
viverci
Esatto A parte a prendere i vostri amici
Mago Merlino E maga Circe è venuta a
stare qui
se
controllo Nel caso dovessero ritornare
altre creature Ma no Merlino sono i
nostri amici pelosetti Merlino è il
nostro cagnolone E circetta invece la
nostra gattina Aspetta un momento però
hai detto altre creature Cosa intendi
dire
mi sono
espressa male Volevo dire che potreste
restare qua in questa casa Sono sicura
che trovereste molto divertente
trascorrere il tempo qui Aspetta sto
pensando una cosa a questo potrebbe
essere finalmente l'occasione per
realizzare il mio sogno quale sogno il
mio sogno il mio sogno Ecco devi sapere
il mio sogno e aprire un'agenzia
investigativa
investigare Ma io sono bravissimo ad
investigare potevi investigare ad
esempio su tipo se c'è un biscotto e poi
all'improvviso scompare la crema io
posso investigare su come ha fatto con
la crema a scomparire anche se nella
maggior parte dei casi con la crema
intendo questo intendo un'agenzia
investigativa in cui potremo indagare su
tutti i tipi i fenomeni paranormali noi
potremmo essere gli investigatori poi
magari potremmo creare un team di
persone che ci aiutano non lo so uno
scienziato un inventario un mostrologo o
una strega un fuoco
un'idea strepitosa Con tutto lo spazio
che avete a disposizione qua
semplicissimo creare la vostra agenzia
Ma sì come metodo di pagamento potremmo
ad esempio accettare
torte cannoncini cannoncini della crema
ma anche Sophie parmigiano
Noi accettiamo la tua proposta e non ti
preoccupare per la casa Ce ne prenderemo
cura sicuramente oggi è solo così
emozionato finalmente aprire una nostra
agenzia investigativa E allora io vi
saluto il mio treno sta per partire ed è
meglio che mi sbrighi ogni tanto tornerò
a
trovare Bene cari Arrivederci
[Musica]
[Applauso]
fiamma aspetta Ciao fiamma volevamo
augurarti un buon viaggio e buona
fortuna per le tue scoperte buon viaggio
Ciao grazie ancora grazie a voi ragazzi
tornerò prestissimo Arrivederci
ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]
beh ora non ci manca che una sola cosa
il nome dell'agenzia investigativa che
noi potremmo dare alla nostra agenzia
investigativa di misteri e cose
soprannaturali scrivetecelo nei commenti
Non vedo l'ora vivremo un sacco di
avventure assieme Mi raccomando lasciate
un mi piace iscrivetevi e attivate la
campanella e teniamoci pronti per i
nuovi casi da risolvere insieme
[Musica]